yo it's your boy designer and check me
out on the bootleg cab podcast you dig
bootleg cat podcast we got a special
guest in here my guy designer what's
goodie what's goody big cat what's up
man how you been bro everything's 30
everything's 30 man you feel me playing
out music man just keep going staying
focused staying in the high you know I
mean you know now I was out of trouble
you uh had obviously man uh when pnb
passed away that hit you hard it hit me
hard man he used to record here it's
been on my show many times
um and I felt like for a while there
like you kind of might have been done
with Music Man yep
um yeah
want to pay me man I have one I'm losing
like three friends in a month and all
that should be okay and um where they
just like you know what I mean hit me
yeah right after the session I was just
recording you know what I mean on our
journey you know what I'm saying yeah
and then my boy I just called him like
yo bro I love you uh uh you know what
I'm saying he was just like word man we
need more love
um you fool me we just lost tape yeah
and um it just was it's just bad man it
was bad to hear that [ __ ] for me yeah so
I have one up you know what I mean just
before me slam it all out you told me I
had nobody there to talk to at that
moment right so I just let it all out
you know what I mean um just rebirth
myself you know what I'm saying or how
well I was about to say how do you feel
mentally now like are you it feels like
you're back you got your head back in
the game on the rap [ __ ] I appreciate it
yeah heck yeah it feels amazing word man
I feel like that was um you know take
pnb my boy you know what I mean a lot
ticket passed away in the hood I'm just
they just you know I mean lose it to
Industry friends you know what I mean
just really just then it gave me like oh
sprouted just keep going bro like don't
give up you know what I'm saying like I
feel like none of them would want me to
ever give up before I'm saying or what I
put my you know my spits that the stone
to do you know what I mean what I really
wanted to do in this keep focusing what
we doing
touching the people and giving them the
energy spreading the messages the
knowledge and just love if I'm saying
keep going for me yeah that's funny man
you were talking earlier when you came
into you you [ __ ] with psychedelics
pretty heavily uh you did yeah
man all the way so you say you've done
yeah whatever what was that like us man
it was yo man
amazing words that's
like hard to explain Express right like
yeah you think I'm saying but it's uh
it's it's it's it's it's it's lovely man
it put you on so much of a higher
surface if I'm saying that when you can
see life front to back you know what I
mean and
just like what they say last 15 minutes
you know what I mean and it felt like
you there for a lifetime you told me you
feel like you see life now after the
journey it's way more like
and a higher frequency you know what I'm
saying like thinking bigger if I'm
saying way larger like you know I mean
even the words you're using is careful
for me you're more careful with certain
things yeah where just understanding is
it's an ultra power install you know I
mean Star Wars type Bob how long ago did
you first try it uh so uh
suit like I tried my first one
if I had the pen the Pen's not the same
right yeah I had the pen and then I had
one up coming home because what happened
was I did it in Atlanta my boy had wound
up giving it to me before I'm saying out
there we was chilling out there and um
it was Bob see if I'm saying it was
Bob's and I was just like kicking back
I'm like when I get to La I'm gonna do
this the right way you're wrong
crazy root crazies crazy strong man and
it it took me you know what I mean yeah
my body and then from there I just was
seeing the Galaxy being and you know
what I'm saying I'm in the Galaxy I seen
the land of fire I'm saying word like
you know I mean nothing but perception
no legs no nothing you for me but just
seeing the being and like it's just like
word is the soul presence I didn't seem
like
the the beans that was like
black Aura I mean black but we're right
over around them bro right you told me
it was wavy bro like that before yeah
yeah you know what I'm talking about you
but I'm saying so it's like so I've not
I haven't done DMT I've done shrooms
heavy and I've had some pretty deep
trips but I heard DMT like you're not
the same like you see you kind of like
come out on the other side of it I've
had like people I know say that they
like were atheists prior to that and
then they do DMT and they're like no
there's a God it's like I saw him or I
felt that energy I felt that presence of
higher power what up that's why I locked
with your eyes man because I feel like
you know what I'm saying words so how
often are you shrooming you micro dosing
oh man definitely bro just like yo
anytime like anytime I really like get
my chance and I feel the vibe too I'm
really into but I'll be doing it more
than often like I I just gave it like
probably four days off just now five
days you can just micro dose and have a
productive day right yeah what up what
up again that's when Johnny at the time
I'll be doing I'm micro dosing if I'm
saying if I'm moving through the day
then when I get back to the crib you
know I'm into like five yeah man to take
it up and that's fireman yeah
um recently you you went online because
there was this discussion about Kodak
Black versus 21 Savage and your freshman
cover now
uh you had something to say about that
because you do have a uh I mean Panda's
a [ __ ] how many times Platinum oh man
it's on two times Diamond eight times
Platinum
wow eight times Platinum yeah in the US
word that's so crazy hey what up y'all
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our family at my
bookie man it's my favorite time of the
year we got World Cup NBA and NFL
football going on at the same time
there's so many opportunities for you to
make some money all you got to do is go
to my bookie right now use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for a new
account they're gonna match your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars that
means you go to my bookie you put in 500
bucks for your first deposit using that
promo code bootleg they're gonna give
you another 500 to gamble with for free
free money you could put that on
whatever's going on this weekend in
football
uh maybe you want a better future who
you think's gonna win the Super Bowl
maybe you want to do a future on the
World Cup who do you think's gonna win
the World Cup if you're trying to NBA
championship maybe you want to bet Luka
doncic is going to score between 31 and
35 points tonight whatever it is you can
gamble on it at my bookie and they're
giving you free money if you [ __ ] with
that promo code bootleg trust me man
I've been getting this money now I'm not
saying that you're gonna win like me
because you know I got the [ __ ]
picks but if you love sports and you
love to make money gambling on Sports go
to my bookie right now that's my bookie
use the promo code bootleg and they're
going to match your first deposit up to
a thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview but I saw you kind of like put
your like you know hey man don't don't
forget about me over here you know what
I mean and uh I was gonna ask you like
do you feel like you somehow because I
feel like you're overlooked in terms of
that freshman class because you know
your freestyle was so legendary that you
had to make a record on Timmy Turner
[ __ ] turn into a record you know what I
mean I don't think anybody else had a
freshman freestyle that turned into an
actual song yeah this love man I
honestly brought me I was banging on the
fridge I brung that you know I mean that
Talent from there you know I mean the
neighborhood literally I was in the back
of clubs like Timmy Timmy Timmy Turner
yeah you wish foreign
that day it was that moment that time I
was just like yeah I'm gonna bust it
right here you know what I'm saying I
already knew and it turned into a record
yeah you won't sign where I'll be like
working on my [ __ ] you know I mean
saying in front of the people always I'm
always good with the performance man I
go a lot you put me anywhere with the
performance with that oh trust me I've
seen it man the way you throw the mic up
and yeah I saw you uh real 923 we had a
show in like 2017 I think and then
afterwards you did the after party at
Playhouse and you were [ __ ] lit my
boy bro you were throwing you was doing
[ __ ] with the mic and I was just so
impressed because most people would drop
it bust their lip you had all kinds of
some rock star [ __ ] going on I
appreciate it bro
yeah your live Show's insane bro for
sure for sure
um what is something because I you know
I feel like you kind of had like a rough
Shake in terms of like the music
industry kind of ending up over with
Kanye I feel like you were kind of
mishandled you know respectfully
um do you feel like you like what did
you learn from your previous label
situation that you're you can apply to
your career now
um
really just uh
well that's a great question bro I love
that question but um
what I'm moving with now I just really
just like to September you know what I
mean just if I'm saying like word you
know I mean respectfully yeah I mean to
not know offensive out of 10 I was with
former team I was with but just the team
love if I'm saying it's more of a like
compassion is more of it like we we talk
together more onions they checking in
you probably saying it's bigger than
just music with them you know I mean
it's a family you know what I mean and
that's what I got right now you know I
mean with my new situation with Riverton
Andrew Scott Alyssa if I'm saying like
we moving and it's just that love it's
that yo we gonna be going to the top we
getting bigger and bigger what do you
got um in the chamber right now music
wise you got a project coming or you
dropping I know obviously you're
dropping singles and stuff what's next
or um honestly man we got a new album
we're working on right now you know what
I'm saying call you know I mean I'm
gonna start I'm gonna start off with
what's coming out tonight though you
think I said bigger and bigger make sure
y'all tune in it's it's wavy you follow
me triumphing you throw me The Vibes
some of my favorite instruments in the
world yeah we going up we're going up
and then I got got before I'm saying the
vibe of
the problem before me word you know I
mean the album is coming up
new color for me what's the name of the
album new color new color yeah I like
that word what's that mean oh man is
this I'm the way I see things nowadays
big bro like you know what I'm saying
like
the through a new lens you feel me you
know what I mean so it's it's seeing and
reaching for new color you know what I'm
saying so observing in love with color
you know I mean the God what God
creating is you know I mean the vibe but
just the A1 you know what I'm saying
word Star Wars Vibes y'all know Star
Wars
yo uh another situation that you were
part of earlier this year that kind of
went viral was uh you and the STG kind
of had like a public spat because you
didn't like that he was going to charge
you I think it was 50k for reverse right
oh man it's 95. 75 Christ
I remember that number one time but yeah
but you had called them out like I think
a lot of people were kind of critical of
you because they're like hey well he
doesn't know you this what he charges
like it is what it is but you guys kind
of got past that like
um did was there anything you took from
that situation really
um you know I mean um I had to really
come with artists you know I mean
nowadays with the new artists I guess
with like features and stuff because you
know I look I was I was the dude in the
game that's what I'm saying I ain't the
number one Diamond records like we going
up man connects to Kanye West we we
selling out Arenas we doing we doing
things I wasn't really charging people
like that you were doing [ __ ] like a lot
on the strength if you [ __ ] with them if
you know I mean like we've seen each
other I'm a fan and you all like I see
your work yo let's put something
together we just on the planet and this
is the hip-hop culture just making music
so I think you know just the supporters
outside you know they like to see like
collaborations yeah and I just was
trying to put something together so you
know what I mean where that's all yeah
thank you yo um obviously coming into
the game with this song like Panda I
want to say drewski put me onto that
record
come on boys New York New York he had to
be one of the first guys to break that
record yeah
you know Bobby Tran shake the block yeah
but it's crazy because that record was
like such a movement out of New York
City right and then you end up on good
music a version of that song ends up on
T you know the life of Pablo which is
one of my favorite yay albums when did
you first like initially find out yay
was going to use part of panda on
the life of Pablo oh man like bro when
we was over there in the city and be
driving
we just came you know it's 11 label been
and we'll be going crazy everyone's
trying to sign you yo everybody's yellow
on tables are going crazy
being a taxi cab over here is a call
like yo you want to do something with
the record you know what I'm saying
now my lawyer he like
hey yo I think he want to do something
with the ad-libs or something like you
for me like you want three dollars
long story short he like though let's
fly out to LA he tell us to pack up go
to L.A we go up there yo bro I'm over
there like that whole day you know what
I'm saying I was like something you're
just pulling up you know y'all see us
jumping out the car he just in the car
he just had the record right there for
us like you for me looks like yo you
like this
I'm like all right that that's it five
you know what I'm saying at first you
know what I mean and I thought he was
gonna go longer I ain't know like you
know I mean he just was gonna put like
you know he just put like probably like
six balls on it right but I'm saying so
I ain't
I ain't like you know I thought bro was
going he was just like I'm gonna just
let you go crazy bro and I was like yeah
that's fine yeah or then he was like I'm
on my way out he was that's when he was
messing with Kim
and then you ended up signing with good
after that people I'm saying word that
night you know I mean we was in the
studio me and him Mike Dean we was over
there all cooked up it was like Mike
Dean was working on ship for the weekend
and then I just was pulled up it's
playing music he was making music and it
was like we got a sign bro his energy
out of here like
and then we just for me we made a move
what up it's bootleg cab man we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good Folks at Blue chew that's right
fellas if you're dealing with a little
erectile dysfunction yeah dick's not
working like it should be but don't trip
bluetooth's got you yeah maybe you're a
little stressed out
at home at work little performance
anxiety yeah well look don't trip
Bluetooth will make your dick rock hard
oh yeah that's right super hard uh all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com use
the promo code bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g for you non-spelling [ __ ]
out there use that promo code they're
gonna send you a month supply of
Bluetooth for free what is Bluetooth you
ask well let me tell you the same active
ingredient as Viagra anacialis
minus the awkward doctor's visits nobody
wants to go to a [ __ ] doctor's office
sit in line you're reading an old-time
Magazine from three years ago waiting
for your name to get caught you can go
in there and tell your doctor your dick
ain't working like it should be
nobody wants to do that nope put on
bluetooth.com it's all online they send
it right to your door discreet packaging
in a chewable form
look what are we talking about use the
promo code bootleg get a month for free
all you have to do is pay five dollars
in shipping all right and they just did
their Bluetooth mint chewable the same
active ingredient as Levitra
which is a little extra hitter you know
what I mean so fellas ladies Etc if you
need to you know get your dick right go
to bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and try it for a month for free
free
what are we doing we're getting back to
the interview that's what we're doing
was there ever a point in time you
regretted signing with good because you
had you could assign with anybody
um yeah definitely worked for me I um
many people try to sign me man that's
what I'm saying even you chose Kanye
probably over everybody because at that
time that record was so beautiful you
know what I mean you know what I mean
like it was different like you told me
like and obviously there was like the
highs of the good music situation but
obviously they were the lows and that's
not just for you as an artist there's a
lot of artists that we're all good that
like you know probably deserve more
attention yeah it worked before I'm
saying it was a it was a lot of people
that were trying to sign me the reason
why I'm saying that you know I mean
because you know some artists that's you
know other artists that tried to sign me
as well you know what I'm saying well
yeah this is you know who else try to
sign you that like who is the closest
besides yay that you were that you were
looking at in terms of just like
potentially signing with other artists
other artists Ross MMG
anybody out of New York bad boy
oh Coke Boys Coke Boys that would have
been crazy right up and um that was real
you know that [ __ ] for real for real bro
every time I see you it's a movie man
and that's the reason um it was a couple
artists no man well there's a couple
artists though my boy French I ain't
gonna say all the artists but it's no
that's no French yeah French French is a
great CEO too man yeah salute to him
recipes to chinks
um it's dope too man because I feel like
you're in a really rare position where
you know a lot of people might have had
your journey in this music industry and
like been discouraged or allowed to like
I'm sure at times it was like mentally
taxing for you but it feels like man
you're coming out on the other side of
like this [ __ ] I appreciate what I'm
saying yeah do you feel like musically
you're in the best space you've been in
a long time in terms of just being
creative and yeah we're definitely being
able to be something with myself before
I'm saying like I had a um I was in a
relationship and [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying just got out that situation
positive or negative toxic not toxic
Christian rock blue face type of [ __ ]
but it was you know I mean you know I
had you know I had to just get my vibes
I feel like I had the game myself you
know what I'm saying like word you know
decide to really set myself in and just
build up pandemic it was just a little
different you know what I'm saying like
I felt like I was doing my I was seeing
myself in the same cycle that's what me
and shorty like kind of like separated
at that time you feel me he wasn't as
close to as much so it was just like you
know she on the East Coast I'm on the
west coast right I'm out here I'm
building the crib out you know what I'm
saying doing [ __ ] with the crib so I
just was like more alone if I'm saying
to myself and then from that you know I
mean flights all that stuff covid people
being separated and it's like you know I
mean we just became like more like this
distance you know what I'm saying and
then right I feel like it was a good
thing though for real because it changed
me bro that's where this you know the
journey psychedelics started yeah if I'm
saying it started seeing life from from
small from the end to
from the plant to you know what I mean
to the way I'm eating you know what I'm
saying to how I fix my diet how I fix my
mom you're vegan now yeah for me hey
to tell you about our family at Odd
Socks that's right the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board you know what I mean we
get to put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview hold up how long has
that been no no word for the system um
beginning of the pandemic I've been
doing the you know what I mean the
chicken noodle soups all day we're first
pan in the cabin I was going over there
the Olive Garden of course
it's funny Bros Bunny man but definitely
definitely man I had the uh full vegan
yeah and you and you feel good yeah what
do you miss what food do you miss the
most though oh man your phone's saying I
ain't gonna lie man you ain't gonna get
me started man
he tried to get me back in my graveyard
man you mistake you what do you missed
what's the one thing if you could have
one cheat meal
Oreo milkshake an Oreo milkshake yeah
that's right you can't have a milkshake
because you're vegan so my guy right
there is vegetarian so he's still he's
still no no not him
so Cyrus vegetarian so he still has milk
and cheese and [ __ ] yeah I'm not but I I
ain't like you know I mean what would
inspired you to be vegan was it like
because you love animals or because it
was a health thing no situation problems
on stage with fun flex you can see it
show me this vomiting on stage if I'm
standing in the middle of the show a
couple shows like you know what I'm
saying word even with Alyssa was it
because you were out of shape is it were
you drunk or yo I noticed when I'm
eating meat that's a lot of acid
overloads yeah and if I'm doing liquor
and all that [ __ ] that ass to start
building up like I'm saying crazy so
yeah like I saw the notice some moments
and I just took it easy I just take it
easy with that [ __ ] confession for me
it'd be [ __ ] me up even in my sleep I
was over there like waking up out of
sleep like oh [ __ ] throwing up throwing
them out the guy [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying have you uh calmed down on
drinking what's up you know I mean it's
a Vibe it's a creative it's a creative
tool I use it as a creative tool yeah
do you feel like you ever had a problem
drinking yeah it was like you're
drinking too much no no that's good
that's not my vibe yeah I mean I I I
mean my parents they was alcoholic I'm
saying so and they out that situation by
the grace of God you know and right man
so I seen that [ __ ]
young up close a little bit hey how long
did it take after you started to pop off
before you hung out with Iman Shumpert
so we didn't uh so we didn't realize
y'all were the same yeah it was ASAP man
it was quick right because it was like
was he on the Knicks at the time or was
he on the Cavs okay okay and it was on
yo bro it was it was I go live bro it
was ASAP man it was ASAP man it was just
like go to internet picked up on it I'm
like yo damn I do like this door yeah
nobody said word when he came up to New
York you know what I'm saying I gotta
take a picture together with him and Mom
Dukes man it was it was like yo man we
all look just alike
I wonder because when you first came out
your the future comparisons were crazy
right did you and future ever have any
interactions or any did you ever meet
him or because obviously he's tied with
with yay and you know but was it was
that ever like did you guys have a
conversation or have any interaction nah
man
and it's crazy because when you talk you
just sound like you so it's kind of was
that ever frustrating hearing those
comparisons because you're like I'm just
I'm just me like like the way you talk
is how you sound when you rap so it's
not like you're trying to sound like
nobody yeah bro I don't know bro yeah
I'll be just chilling bro like oh there
was a dude named do you remember gorilla
black from Compton gorilla black comedy
so there's a guy named gorilla black
from Compton okay and he sounds just
like biggie also shine remember you
remember Sean when shine first came out
I don't know if he was saying but then
when you would hear shine talking
interviews yeah I remember like that's
just his voice
too my brother-in-law was telling me
about him when I was younger too he was
like yo get some kid in gorilla black
but that's crazy it's kind of similar
like yo you this is just your voice like
what do you want me to do you want me to
like we have a similarity in voice what
the [ __ ] you want from me you can't win
you filming I don't know I don't know
man I don't know bro hey we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our family at hard Dean that's
right hard Dean Las Vegas the craziest
dispensary in the world the number one
dispensary in the United States let
alone in Las Vegas all right maybe
you're hitting Vegas with your friends
your girlfriends whatever maybe it's a
bachelor party whatever's going on
you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell him I
sent you they got the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life the pre-rolls the
cartridges the Edibles the flower all
top notch all the best the bud tenders
are so friendly it smells great it
smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed alright so go follow them right now
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
a follow get all the details you need
you can get you some of this fly ass
Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview what are you doing
in your spare time are you gaming are
you what are you watching now on Netflix
what are you doing in your spare time
for fun man outside of being creative
and making music Superman sign up
playing the game man definitely I like
playing the game I like to be about I
like to really like I'm a real like
nature type guy you understand I'm a
Nature Boy I feel like I get a lot of my
material and [ __ ] from nature so what
are you doing like did you go out to the
[ __ ] force in case I like to watch
like you both saying like octopus and
[ __ ] keep on saying like did you say
like to watch watch octopus octopus
you ever see uh that the octopus escaped
the boat yo man [ __ ] octopus are like
alien life form they're so smart yo you
think I'm saying you phone me my mind me
just on other creatures and like she'll
be watching like YouTube videos no
whales and [ __ ] you told me I had a
dream I was with a well word up out of
out of the world that [ __ ] was crazy
actual whale actual not a BBW just the
actual well yeah had a couple of those
two you know I mean
so the album is called new color yeah
new color new color new color okay new
song out by the time they watch this the
song will be out yeah man you think I'm
saying word you know I mean bigger
booger we going crazy I already know the
whole world I started in the record I
chanted in the record y'all know are we
coming we going bigger and bigger man uh
any collabs on the album uh definitely
bro we got some collapse you know what
I'm saying uh you know what I mean I
wanna I wanna drop some you know what I
mean but man
yeah some features
we'll wait we'll wait until you release
the track listing yeah you did I got you
is it uh potentially possible that you
have the best ad-libs of all time you
think I'm saying I appreciate that [ __ ]
because I didn't say you did I said it's
possible you definitely top five it's
like designer it's it's uh Jeezy
who else got the crazy ad libs
I just think of it
got shot at the Migos man the Migos mama
mama oh yeah the Migos are up there for
sure but you got dude for a while there
but I think when I first saw you in
person I was just like this guy is the
most energetic you're like a [ __ ] pro
wrestler I appreciate it bro what up man
WWE man you already know the Vibes all
that [ __ ] yo I wonder as somebody who
was at a point in time close with the a
his current [ __ ] that's happening it's
very disappointing how do you feel about
kind of what's been going on with him
um
I feel like you just trying to be heard
a little bit if I'm saying at the same
time you know you know but
hey man I'm gonna be easy with this
because it's a it's a strong topic yeah
it's something you you don't want to say
the wrong thing you got a tightrope it
yeah so you know I mean like you throw
me like
bro you for me like you didn't see
anything you didn't see any of that side
of him though when you were working with
him obviously like you know I mean like
yeah it was small to himself before I'm
saying yeah I try to get up even more to
himself before I'm saying so you know
what I mean um there's that man well
look new color coming soon yeah you're
from top of the Year thank you brother
uh top of the Year y'all know the Vibes
2023 it's a movie anything else you got
anything else going on you want to
promote besides the music uh sit man son
more life I just want to promote more
life to the world that's what I'm saying
and even about the situation yeah I
could I could say this about it um we
all Brothers yeah we all sisters get
along you know what I'm saying stay
strong live long before me that's the
goal for me we put together we create
together and we build together
with no building then it's destroying
remember that so just stay on that for
me there's only two sides you could play
build or destroy so boom designer with
some gym stay in the interview what up
brother boom my guy appreciate you
brother yes sir thank you fire